we're going to be looking at uh within
the nature of proof
uh this is actually kind of the last
sort of section within this topic of
proof
uh much shorter than complex numbers
though to be fair
um we actually did two big chunks of
complex numbers
that the syllabus treats separately we
just kind of did them as one big hole
that's why it
took all of last term okay and you're
like whoa
it's only week four um what's going on
there so
yes we are coming toward the end because
it's a shorter topic i will point out
though that even this is the last kind
of section
um there are many things underneath this
one heading as you'll discover over the
next
week and which you partly already know
from the mathematics extension one
induction that you have done
from last year now back in the time when
um
when people wanted to watch a tv show
they did not just get to a binge watch
all 17 episodes in one hit
you actually had to wait like seven days
you'd watch an hour and then you'd be
like oh no
i have to wait a whole week to find out
what happens a week would pass and then
you know they had to assume you probably
forgot what happened in the last episode
so they would sometimes begin
previously in what's what's on tv these
days
um i'm just trying to think i know
previously on wonder vision or whatever
happened to me
that you were watching right uh well i
guess one division is doing that because
they are making you wait duh
disney anyway i'm gonna do that
for you now because it was some time ago
that we had a look at induction so help
me remember um how does induction
work there's kind of three main steps
that go into
every a single proof by induction and
they helpfully make a very nice
acronym that's like ironically
convenient can anyone tell me what's the
first
thing you do regardless of what result
you've got what's the first step
okay we proved the base case i'm going
to say
t for test just because i'm going to use
the letter p
for something else in a second um so we
test the base case
and you know if it's a proper proof by
induction we assume it works okay
that that checks out fantastic what's
the next thing we do
we assume right so we say this
statement that you're presenting to me
i'm just gonna assume it's true for some
arbitrary number right we tend to say uh
we tend to call that number
k right so we've got that assumption we
just literally
write that down and then the real work
begins what is the final
most important step okay so we're
required to
prove that the statement is
true not for n equals k because we
already assumed that but for n
equals the next case right
and this is where usually the bulk of
our thinking actually goes
so um i said it's a convenient acronym i
don't know if you got that
better for for you you know mrs lees and
i love metaphors um
the way induction works is it starts
from this initial case
and then once you prove this logic you
can then get all of the cases
subsequently
to just collapse like you're tapping a
chain of dominoes right so it's like oh
wonderful this works or maybe you heard
the latter analogy
so you just you don't tap ladders though
okay now
this is what we did i want to ask you
see if you can remember
if we go back like earlier on there were
really two
categories of things that we asked you
to prove
within mathematics extension one i know
i'm sort of pulling on like old threads
here but i wonder if
within the whole class we can remember
what were the two overall categories or
problems we could um or
statements we could prove within
extension one and you remember
okay
all right hold on divisibility i paused
because i was like ooh is your finished
if
is your sentence finished um
divisibility let's just remember what
that is
you've got some expression usually some
algebraic expression and they say
for all of the values that you put into
this it'll always be
divisible by six or seven or eight which
is which is kind of cool
now then should be said arithmetic
within that more specifically there was
something we spent a lot of time on it
was actually a new topic
from last year do you remember when you
have like
think about this we're like adding up a
bunch of different things as you go
further and further
yeah very good so it was almost always
series of some kind and by the way
i suppose we could have geometric ones
in there too there's no reason why you
couldn't have
both of those right now you may have
gone in each of your classes
a little bit further past that because
actually within the extension one course
of the past
there used to be a lot more under
induction um and
part of the reason why we're kind of
like in our brains and in our textbooks
we're like oh you if you can do these
you can handle other ones
as well but in our new world uh what we
call
further very undescriptive words now we
have more of it to do
in extension two we reserve much more
challenging kinds
of mathematical induction to do for
instance what was the last thing the
very last thing we looked at within
extension two nature of proof what kind
of objects we're looking at starts with
an eye
we're looking at inequalities right so
we would say oh can you prove
some expression like uh i don't know
something like this
for some particular values right we can
do
several of these proofs by induction but
we don't do that with an extension one
we do it
in extension two okay so we're going to
add to this we're going to put
what did i just say we're going to put
inequalities under here we're going to
put geometry under here we're going to
put
calculus under here that's what i'm
going to spend over the next few lessons
but today i just want to focus on one of
the key differences which is very early
on
it's with this you usually kind of skip
over this like it's sort of a brainless
step right in extension one there's a
good reason for that
uh what is the base case usually in
extension one
it's usually just one sometimes will
throw a zero at you but that's it
in extension one it's zero or it's one
and importantly
going on down to this last step here if
we start with one
then the next one's two and then three
and then four
within extension two we say well what if
the gap between each of those
increments isn't just one what if we
wanted say
the even integers then n equals k plus
one
would not be the next case it'd be n
equals k plus
2 because that's the gap between the
even numbers there's no reason why we
can't have other gaps
as well multiples of three multiples of
whatever i want
okay so that's going to be the first
distinction that we have a look at
so as an example and uh pick up your
pens if you haven't already
this is the first one we're going to do
for instance
prove remember of a goldfish
[Applause]
two to the end it's going in this way
four
okay
i don't need this thing at the top
anymore now
having just reviewed a little bit of
your brain for how induction works maybe
you feel like
i could totally make a start on this and
i'm going to ask you to do that
in a second but before we do as i
pointed out before
the first difference in extension 2 is
this very first step
not a major difference but this first
step is going to be substantially
different you can't test n equals 1
for this i mean just have a quick look
at it right
is this always going to work 1 2 3 4 etc
you can clearly see there are going to
be some small values for which this is
not
going to work n equals three for example
right
uh eight not bigger than nine okay so
where are we going to begin
given the particular restriction that
i've provided for you
five because i've said n is greater than
four not including four
right and i'm dealing with i mean it's
induction so i'm dealing with whole
numbers so let's go ahead and just say
test n equals 5.
now i've not just given you a uh
different start
uh for for n i've also given you an
inequality
so it's not just as simple as just put
it in and see what happens
i'm just going to give you it'll look
weird but i'm going to give you a
recommendation for how to set out this
next bit being that we've got an
inequality
i'm going to test this in the right hand
side first
seems weird why am i starting with the
right you'll see why in about 45 seconds
not complicated right hand side in this
case for n equals five equals
it's 25 right there's my five squared
how many times now i'm going to go to
the left hand side
the left-hand side is 2 to the power of
5. to the power of 5
is
32 come on guys powers are 2. they're
not that hard right
now why have i wanted to start with the
right hand side it's so that for this
next line
ah i've already got the right hand side
i've now just established that the left
hand side
is bigger than the right hand side
yeah do you see that left hand side
stays on the left hand side and my
inequality is facing in the same
direction do you remember on tuesday i
said unlike equations you've got to be
quite careful with which direction
things are flying
and this just lets you write the left on
the left and the right on the right if
you had started
with the left and then finished with the
right you have to write it backwards
okay there's my base case happy times
i think you guys know how to assume that
this is going to be true
for n equals k so i'm not going to write
that i'll write that in a second
but then lastly and i'm going to get you
to have a go at this right when you do
your proof step
when you do your proof step for now
we're just thinking about like
four uh sorry five six seven and so on
so worry about
bigger gaps in my next example our next
example
but i'm just gonna warn you right
normally you just
assume then you'd write down your k plus
one and then you just
start turning the handle right and you
look for some place
that you can potentially substitute in
your assumption
right i'm just going to give you two
questions question number one these are
inequalities
inequalities are a little bit dicey to
just substitute into
than equations right if the things are
equal in equations then you just
pop it in right with inequalities we've
seen already you have to be a little
more cautious it's doable
i think you guys can manage it without
me like walking your hand you know
holding your hand through it
walking your hand but i'm just flagging
it right now okay there's the first one
the second one is because this is true
right and um emmanuel i were just
talking about this yesterday actually
we don't give you information in a
question it's a bit of a bad habit of
math teachers actually
we don't give you information in a
question unless it is relevant
right um i already just pointed out this
doesn't work for any course
three right it doesn't even work for n
equals two because then you have a
they're equal
i want it to be greater than right so
you're going to have to make use
of this fact somehow right you're not
just going to be calling on this
assumption that you're about to make two
to the k is greater than k squared you
somehow are going to have to bring in
this once you are doing k's and stuff
like that you have to say k is greater
than 4 as well
okay that's a bit trickier and you may
not be able to do that
on your own so i'm going to give you a
few minutes to have a place see how far
you can get
those are the two questions i'm going to
give you and then we'll come back
together after we've
seen how you went with it off you go
i will acknowledge right from the outset
as with most of the proofs we've dealt
with uh not just in this topic but like
in all mathematics many ways to go about
this and in fact
mrs elizabeth and i have had this
conversation many times i'm going to
give you a proof in a second
i'm not convinced that all that it is
the best proof or the most elegant proof
even i as i write it i'm like
i think i could do better than this but
i think what i'm about to present to you
well it might be it's going to take a
few lines okay i'm going to get there
but i hope the thing about it that's
best is even if it's not the most
concise i think it's probably the
clearest one that i can come up with so
here we go when it starts with
inequalities if you think back to
tuesday's lesson there are several
overall strategies that you can use to
approach inequalities
of any kind one of them was to
just start with something that you know
and then work with that
right now in this context the only thing
that i kind of really know that's that's
relevant
is my assumption i'm assuming that to be
true so i'm just going to write
by assumption
and let's just state to the k is greater
than
k squared this is a bit different to a
lot of the proof spy
induction that we've done in the past
often with like these guys here right
more frequently you would start with
something like maybe the left or the
right hand side and then you start doing
some stuff to it and then you'll be like
aha i found
the assumption and then you do a
substitution like three or four lines in
okay so that's a distinction here with
inequalities not always but this is
often a helpful thing to do